hello everyone I hope you're all having
a wonderful Sunday I'm feeling a little
bit better so I decided to show you
another game it's a very nice attacking
game and the difference between these
games at this game and other games
between alpha 0 and stockfish is that
the ones we've seen so far have been
played without opening books and this
one it's played using opening books and
positions that were used in the 2016 TCC
so the top chess engine competition
so the first the first 12 moves are book
based and the day and the Alpha and
stockfish take it from them so let's
check out this very nice game it's
really a wonderful attacking him and
alpha just shows us how how things are
done and how one one is supposed to push
pawns to win games so let's check it out
we have d4 by alpha the 5 c4 c6 so the
Slav defense knight to have three
Knights to have six nights the c3 in
Mount Isa so this is all standard theory
East III Knight B to d7 Queen to c2 and
the Bishop to d6 and here we have g4 it
seems like a like a pawn sacrifice but
not really this is the main line of this
of this stalls line of the Slav where
black if black captures then we go into
room g1 and black they don't really win
a pawn or anything simply after h5h
three night goes back a white will win
back the pawn on g7 and while you have
some tricks here for example black and
gold Knight to g4 and let's say after H
captures on g4 you could go Queen to f6
wouldn't attack on the rook and also on
the knight on f3
so after okay seven as the Queen is
protecting him captures captures and
after Queen captures on f3
White will capture on h5 and the White
will always be better here so black
didn't really achieve anything by
grabbing this pawn so instead Bishop to
b4 and this is still everything from the
book
Bishop to d2 we have Queen e7 rook to g1
now supporting the g4 pawn Bishop
captures on c3 better captures on c3 and
the Knights to e4 we have queenside
castle Kings at castle and
up up until this point this was all
moves from the book and it's interesting
there exists a game between Nakamura and
Lu Chen from 2004 where Nakamura played
Bishop to d3 and the game continues
knife captured Queen captures and the
Nakamura was able to win this game but
it took him some a hundred and eighty
two moves so instead after this castles
alpha zero does not agree with Nakamura
as Bishop to d3 but alpha zero decides
to keep the Bishop so Bishop to e1 and
as of this point this is moved 12 so the
first up until this point the moves were
familiar but already the first move off
a place in this position we have a
completely new game on the board and
okay we have alpha preserves the bishop
pair but stockfish also preserves a very
strong right on e4 so it's a kind of a
trade off b6 preparing to develop the
light square bishop we have h4 my alpha
pushing those pawns they're up to b7 and
now the only way to start an attack and
eliminate blacks from knight on e4 is
nice to g5 this comes with a pawn
sacrifice but alpha doesn't mind that we
have Knight captures pawn captures Queen
captures and now f4 so you've sacrificed
the pawn but you've started an attack on
the King side you have a semi-open
H file for your rook and the Queen at
some point I moved like rook to h1 Queen
to h2 perhaps will be possible with a
with a nice attack against the black
King Queen to e7 and now comes King to
be one you don't want to start an attack
against the King said before this very
nice prophylactic King to be won at some
point you know that the rook will come
to c8 and perhaps the C file will open
so you don't want your king and queen to
be occupying the same file c5 by
stockfish Bishop to d3
the threat is to capture on h7 so uh
stockfish defenses we have g6 and now c
captures on d5 now if you reply e
captures on d5 you've closed the bishop
you're no longer controlling h1 and now
Queen to H 2 followed by rook to h1
could be very unpleasant so we have C
captures on d4 and now this same idea of
Queen h2 can be met with Russia
seventy-five we're now h1 is controlled
and afteri for rush up the b7 rock h1
going after the h7 pawn black can defend
with f6 and now the Queen is defending
the h7 pawn black is up material and we
will most likely defend and enjoy a
better game so this will be too slow so
instead a four by alpha and here if you
play pawn captures then you get a five
nothing to be done here so stock which
simply develops the rook rook a to ca to
put an attack on the Queen and only now
Queen to h2 we have f6 a pre-emptive
defensive move as the Queen is now
already guarding the h7 pawn and here D
captures only six will be too slow
because now black will not recapture
immediately first night to c5 and now
after Bishop to b4 pinning the night
Queen can capture on e6 and now after f5
25 stock which will offer a trade of
Queens and the whites attack is
happening too slow so after f6 alpha
doesn't waste time
f5 immediately and okay we have Eve
capture Sun d5 but now F captures on g
6h captures on g6 and rook to h1 already
threatening Queen to h8 and even though
a stock fish did create an escape route
for his king it will not help him all
that much you don't have time for
something like Punk after Sonny for a
queen h8 checking of 7 and now the rook
will check the king and win the Queen
it's a game over for black
so after rook to h1 we have Queen to g7
not allowing the Queen to land on h8 and
now how do you continue this attack with
white you've already given up some of
your pawns you have to try something if
you try this release your Bishop Bishop
captures on d5 already it comes with an
attack on the rope it's very hard to see
how this attack continues for white
so alpha finds a very nice continuation
of this attack Bishop to c2 and now you
are directly preventing black from doing
D captures on e4 because of Bishop to b3
check and now after rook to f7 blocking
there really isn't anything else you can
block with the Queen due to Queen to a
shade checkmate
so I have to look to f7 rook captures on
d4 even making room for this Bishop to
come to c3 now and after Knight to e5
g5 you're now threatening to open up for
this diagonal and after something like
knife to have three attacking the Queen
and the rook white will easily win with
Bishop captures and now either Queen
captures and queen to HH checkmate
or you can capture with the king and
then rugby 7 check will win after King
moves Queen d6 and you will lose the
Queen and the game and there is one
tricky idea after g5 that stockfish good
to try the the sneaky Knight the d3 but
of course alpha would not fall for this
you could only fall for fall for this if
you go for the same line Bishop captures
King captures rook d7 check King moves
and now if you just capture the Queen
you will get rook the c1 checkmate but
of course I mean it's highly unlikely
that alpha would fall for this after
night d3 you could simply move the
bishop and then no made threats are
available now but a nice thing to show
so after a bishop to see - we have
Knight to e5 and now Bishop to b3 just
the same and it's very hard for black
this h-file is completely in control of
white you cannot you can never capture
here and white will at some point
capture and play the six so black will
struggle here g5 and not allowing
White's to put g5 himself and now bush
up to g3 and now what do you play here
that's right is sorry about that
the threat is Bishop captures on e5 if
you try Knight f3 then you get a queen
to f2 attacking the knight and now if
you go back it captures on d5 with east
six to follow so after Bishop the g3 you
have knife captures on g4 and now Queen
to h3 attacking the knight on g4 and now
you can no longer go back if you go 95
and then you get under sub captures pawn
captures and now Queen to e6 check Queen
f7 Queen captures on e5 threatening rook
- ehh checkmate after Queen to f6 you
get Bishop captures on d5 with check
captures captures with check Queen below
King moves and now Queen to d7 you
cannot block check with the rug because
Queen captures rook you would have to
block with the Queen and then Queen
captures on e5 white is just all over
the place
Queen blocks again Queen d7 check Queen
blocks and now Queen to g4 with the
threat of rook to this
winning the Queen and also Queen to g5 a
terrible threat after Queen g6 broke
this rugged e7 check King moves and now
after Queen to h3 there is no way to
stop Queen H a checkmate you can give
one check but still there's no defense
against Queen to h8 now so after this
Queen to h3 you cannot go back you have
to go III so night to e3 comes with an
attack on the rook rook captures on d4
and now comes King / 7 now stockfish is
trying to escape with the king also an
interesting move might be nice to see
for simply to diminish the bishops
influence over this diagonal but it
won't it won't work after Queen e6 check
Queen is Queen f7 Queen to f5 now now
you've forced the Queen to come on this
same diagonal is the king and he
captures here and d6 is a terrible
threat after something like rook C to e8
e capture Sun d5 Knight to e3 attacking
the Queen
but then Queen to d3 and the d6 is
coming ooh black will be lost here so
after rook captures on d4 we have killed
the d7 trying to escape but now Bishop
to have to with a double attack against
the night and here you can't really do
anything with the night the pawn is
controlling 5-point is controlling g4
we've already seen that Knight to c4
doesn't work so black tries a rope to h8
and here of course you don't want to
capture on a lot of rope captures on h1
black would of course be winning here
but you can play the very nice Queen to
d7 check and this is what alpha played
and now everything falls into place King
to g6 Queen captures this comes with
check King captures rook captures with
captures and loud the knight allies
undefended on e3 Bishop captures and now
rook to e8
we have looked to a for going after the
a7 pawn we have a six and now Bishop
captures and b6 but now pawn captures on
e3 and as you can see alpha is up a
piece but stockfish has three connected
passed pawns if you can push one of
these pawns
really quickly then surely that will be
compensation enough for the piece but
alpha doesn't allow it
rook to d4 the thread is rook to d7
check winning the bishop and let's see
just what happens if
stockfish ignores alpha l simply pushes
the pawn then room d7 checker King moves
rook captures on b7 and now after e to
wife will simply prevent the pawn you
will bring a queen into the game but she
captures rook captures and after work
the c2 White will very quickly win the
a6 pawn but then the rook and Bishop and
King will be more than capable of
stopping the two pawns and the white
will then also have to pass pawns on the
Queen side with a winning game so
stockfish goes rook to c8 sorry bishop
the c8 but now alpha does it differently
and we have King the c1 brings the King
into the game III pushes the past pawn
but now rook the d8 alpha forces a trade
of rooks and finds that this is winning
for him you have to trade rooks as the
bishop will fall Sohrab captures Bishop
captures and now King to g6 but now as
the e3 pawn is pushed so far away there
is no way to protect him with anything
so Bishop to b6 we have brush up to be
seven and now better to see to check we
have King to f7 and Bishop captures on
e3 King to e6 we have King to d2 we have
King to d6 and now Bishop to d3 and it
was in this position that stockfish
resigned the game one pawn is no
compensation for the piece and however
white plays this this will be a winning
endgame so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it and really do hoping
you're having a better Sunday than me
I'm still under under the influence of
my my flu but yeah I'm really really
happy about this game and have really
satisfied in how alpha just pushes
pushes pushes blocks everything you know
constricts any movement by stockfish and
then it seems a starfish position simply
deteriorate deteriorates
upon itself and at some point you just
have to give up a piece I mean and move
34 alpha is already up a piece and you
know being able to calculate out
everything precisely has a very nicely
winning game and it always reminds me
for example my father-in-law he would
always play against stockfish and he
would always play attacking moves he
would always just attack attack attack
everyone would always tell him you can't
beat stockfish like that but you know no
no it seems that he was right all along
that this is in fact a way to play
against dogfish so yeah I really found
that very funny but yeah like I said I
do hope you enjoyed the game I would
like to think code works
Angus McCloud Alexandra leper and [ __ ]
[ __ ] and Ronald Wagner for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thankful for watching and I will see you
soon hopefully with some more
interesting videos and without the the
crackling voice and this so yeah yeah
thank you all and I will see you soon
[Music]